awesome well welcome everyone i am so
glad that you have joined us today uh
for earth day 2021 and also for this to
celebrate um and honor and recognize uh
dr john p wyatt um in the symposium
focusing on environment and health i
first want to recognize uh dr wyatt's
family for their generous support to
make this event possible um they are
have honored their the legacy of dr
wyatt who was a pathologist
um who was one of the first physicians
in the united states
that air quality and air pollution
specifically
with lung disease so if this was before
earth day even began he was doing this
research so it's an honor for the
university of kentucky to hold this
legacy of the connection between
environment and health particularly from
a physician's point of view
so
uh someone welcome to everyone uh we're
so glad you're here i wanna say that you
are joined i know virtually um but in
the in the spirit of um camaraderie
there are over 360 attendees
from all over the united states joining
us in here in your in the meeting room
today so take time there's a chat
function um you might connect to
colleagues that you may have not seen
over the over the past year year and a
half
um
just to feel a sense of connectedness
so this event also would not have been
possible if it um
from all of the other support from
university partners um
the
dr wyatt left a legacy a true legacy
because now there are over like 10
environmental groups
on our campus
we have two niehs which is the national
institute of environmental health
sciences
funded centers one is the superfund
research center and the other is the uk
care center for appalachian research and
environmental sciences
we also have participating today the
kentucky water research resources
research institute the kentucky animal
disease mapping initiative
uh our the kentucky geological survey
our uk office of sustainability global
environmental health initiative
we also have the center for clinical and
translational science participating um
as well as the tracy farmer institute
for sustainability in the environment
so
uk is a full of wonderful environmental
health research
and work initiative
and we're glad to assemble them all
together today to make this event happen
i want to introduce now the keynote
speaker for the john p wyatt symposium
uh i'm as i am just so honored and
delighted uh to have dr howard frumpkin
with us uh this afternoon
dr frumkin is a professor emeritus of
environmental and occupational health
sciences at the university of washington
school public health in seattle
he served there as dean from 2010 to
2016.
dr frumkin receives his medical degree
from the university of pennsylvania um
and also his mph and drph from harvard
university
he's not only an internist and dedicated
occupational environmental health
medicine specialist but he's also an
epidemiologist one of my favorite fields
and now as we go through the coco
pandemic we realize how important
epidemiology is to our our life and
sustainability
dr franken has spent his entire career
examining the role of the built
environment climate change energy policy
and today we'll hear more about
about that in his in his talk
served as the head of our planet our
health initiative at the welcome trust
in london he's also a past director of
the national center for environmental
health at the u.s cdc and also served as
special assistant
uber climate change and health he has
authored over 200 scientific journal
articles and chapters
and also over nine books focused on
environment
and today we'll also be including his
latest book planetary health
protecting nature to protect ourselves
uh we'll be including that as a as part
of a drawing and a raffle for those who
complete the evaluation of today's event
uh we'll be giving away some of his new
one of his new books
so without any further ado
dr franken
welcome to this event and i'm sincerely
looking forward to hearing your talk on
planetary house thank you
erin thank you so much for that nice
introduction and greetings everybody
happy earth day to everybody it's very
nice to be together i only wish that we
could all be together physically in
beautiful kentucky but i know that as
the pandemic comes to an end we will be
able to get together in real life before
too long and we all look forward to that
my topic today is planetary health and
subtitled human well-being on a fast
changing planet what i hope to do is
introduce you to this
exciting new field of planetary health
before i jump in i'd like to acknowledge
that i'm speaking to you from seattle
from the traditional unseated land of
the coast salish peoples and in
particular the duwamish tribe which
inhabited the land where seattle is now
i honor with gratitude the land itself
and the tribes and i also want to
acknowledge with respect and gratitude
the wyatt family
for their support of today's events
my agenda is very simple just three
pieces i'd like to introduce to you the
paradigm of planetary health
work a few examples with you and then
end on a hopeful note because after all
when we ponder the state of the planet
it can be a little gloomy but we need to
maintain lots of hope and there's good
reason to do that
but let's begin by talking about the
paradigm of planetary health
and i'd like to ask you even if you are
a health professional to channel your
inner historian and your inner ecologist
because we need to think broadly and
long term about the issues that i'd like
to discuss today i'd like to go over
seven key concepts with you the great
acceleration uh the concept of deep time
the anthropocene planetary boundaries
the doughnut ecosystem services and the
concept of poly crisis some or all of
which may be new
so let's begin the story here at the
bottom of a coal mine in scotland in
1860. this is where planetary health may
begin now at the time this picture was
drawn cole had of course been known for
a long time and had been used for over a
thousand years as a source of energy
but at this point it was being used on a
very large scale making energy available
on an unprecedented level and
revolutionizing industry i like this
picture because this seated gentleman
apparently thought it was appropriate to
go to the bottom of the coal mine while
wearing his wig and he's sitting there
lighting a pipe or maybe it's a
firecracker i can't tell which
not a good idea to do in a place where
there may be flammable methane gas in
the air but a nice example of the
reckless insouciance that nicely
foreshadows the energy economy of the
next century and a half
or our story may begin here this is 1859
this is the drake well in northwestern
pennsylvania the first commercial oil
well in the united states and possibly
in the world
liquid fuel represented another form of
plentiful energy that was new and before
long revolutionized transportation and
gave rise to a booming synthetic organic
chemical industry
well all that energy that became
available revolutionized the way people
lived and as you can see here
before too long
a couple of decades passed the human use
of energy began climbing dramatically
and most of that energy consisted of
coal
and oil and a little bit later natural
gas which is a kind of an advertising
name it's it's natural in a sense but
not natural in the sense that many of us
use the word these days
and these three fossil fuels which
represented embedded energy from uh
time in the past
helped us
completely revolutionize the human
enterprise
one of the ways we did that was by
upscaling our population population had
been relatively stable during the entire
holocene for about ten thousand years
but with the availability of energy
populations skyrocketed so that we're
now up to almost three times what the
population was as recently as when i was
born
we also scaled up our economic activity
this is a picture of gdp
what you're noticing now by the way is
that the curves that i'm showing all
look alike a long flat line and then a
sudden
uptick
and this is economic activity the gross
domestic product of the world and it has
skyrocketed as well
in fact almost any indicator of human
activity that we can think of from the
use of water to transportation
fertilizer consumption or production of
products such as paper and plastic
the number of mcdonald's outlets you
name it any indicator of human activity
has skyrocketed in the past couple of
centuries and in particular since about
1950 since the end of the second world
war
this scale up is called the great
acceleration and it represents a
complete break with the history of
humanity
now in many ways this has been a great
time to be alive and to be a human
health and well-being have never been
better
these pictures show that illiteracy is
dropping around the world
poverty is dropping even as the global
population has increased
child survival has improved life
expectancy has improved now all of these
health gains are not equitably
distributed unfortunately but they are
real health gains on a global population
basis
good time to be alive and to be a human
but
and there's a but
these gains have come at a cost and the
cost is being borne by our planet so
let's take a look at the planet let's uh
say a few things about the context of
the planet
first by way of setting context if we
scale the planet to the size of a soccer
ball
then the entire biosphere from the
deepest ocean trench to the very top of
the troposphere
is about as thick in proportion as this
layer of cellophane on a soccer ball
it's a very small film on the surface of
the planet
if we consider all of life on earth all
of life in that biosphere it's about 550
gigatons of carbon is represented in
this cartoon
almost all of it is plants
and animal life represents just a tiny
fraction of one percent of life on earth
if we blow up that animal life we can
see that over half of it is insects a
large part of it is fish
in humans we represent again a tiny
fraction of one percent of the animal
kingdom
interestingly
we
eclipse the number of wild mammals that
wasn't always the case but we've changed
the balance of life on earth
and we are overshadowed by the amount of
livestock that we maintain to feed
ourselves
this gives you a little bit of a sense
of how humans have altered the shape of
life on earth
most importantly we are a very small
part of life on earth
we can also think about the issue of
deep time
the planet has been here for four or
five billion years
life appeared about two billion years
ago
vertebrates less than half a billion
years ago
mammals just a couple of hundred million
years ago
primates just 10 million years ago
our species homo sapiens about 200 000
years ago
we emerged from being hunter-gatherers
to growing crops and writing things down
and living in towns just 10 or 12 000
years ago a very brief time
the writer john mcphee has put it
beautifully
consider the earth's history as the old
measure of the english yard the distance
from the king's nose to the tip of his
outstretched hand
one stroke of a nail file on the king's
middle finger erases human history
so we are a small part of life on earth
spatially
and we are late arrivals temporally and
you might think that given that
a brief existence we couldn't really do
much to alter the entire planet
but you'd be surprised we have
the
chemical composition of the atmosphere
has changed in the last century or so
the temperature of the planet has
changed
the ph of the ocean has changed
the distribution of land uses around the
planet has changed
we have lost species at a very high rate
so it's true to say that we no longer
live on the same planet that our great
grandparents did it is a different
planet fundamentally altered
so much so that geologists have
suggested that we've entered a new
geological epoch here is a picture of
deep time and cartoon form this very
thin black layer at the top represents
the holocene epic the last 10 or 12
thousand years since the end of the ice
age when civilization as we know it
arose
and at the top of that is the
anthropocene the geological epic defined
by the fact that humans have enormous
influence over every global process
now that concept of the anthropocene has
also introduced the concept of planetary
boundaries and this is kind of an iconic
picture let me walk you through it if
you haven't seen it before the notion is
that on these nine parameters climate
novel entities is a euphemism for
chemicals that haven't existed before we
produce them as humans
ozone depletion atmospheric aerosol
loading
biodiversity
the way land is used fresh water
availability
biogeochemical flows of phosphorus and
nitrogen and the ph of the ocean
for each of these parameters there is a
boundary beyond which we shouldn't go
if we stay in the green safe zone here
the planet remains stable and life as we
know it can continue we can continue to
thrive
but if we transgress those boundaries
into the red zone here we risk
irreversible system change
and the
scientists who develop this framework
have actually proposed that with respect
to biodiversity we have crossed the line
we are in at the sixth grade extinction
and with respect to phosphorus and
nitrogen flows
human influence on the flows of those
elements now eclipses natural flows
we've changed them fundamentally
now you may wonder where are the people
we can redraw that picture this is the
exact same picture just redrawing with a
big hole in the middle because those of
us in the health professions may be
thinking where are the people these are
all physical processes
so here is a picture drawn with an empty
hole in the middle where the people
ought to go here's the ecological
ceiling with the idea of overshoot and
we can insert into it
people and their needs here's water food
energy social equity peace and justice
all the things that people need
and here is a social foundation below
which we shouldn't go
so ecological limits above which we
shouldn't go
social limits below which we shouldn't
go and that space in the middle is the
sweet spot where we'd like to be
that's called the safe and just space
for humanity
a regenerative and distributive economy
this is the model of the donut economy
put forward by oxford economist kate
rowers so this situates human health and
well-being within the larger context of
a functioning
world
now there's another framework by which
to think about the ways in which
planetary processes support human health
and well-being
and that's the concept of ecosystem
services you may have come across this
before the notion is that when the
planet is operating with uh with
integrity and in a equilibrium manner
it provides supporting services think of
the formation of soil
it provides provisioning services giving
us food water and other things we need
it provides regulating services think of
a
a a coastal forest protecting us from
floods
and it provides cultural services like
our ability to enjoy the beauty of
nature and to be
physically active in natural settings
all of these services as you can imagine
can be mapped to the ingredients of
human health and well-being
and that's what's done in this
complicated picture from the millennium
ecosystem assessment
here's health which is what brings us
all together today but it's accompanied
by the basic materials for a good life
by security and by good social relations
what you can see is that these ecosystem
services map directly to health as well
as to other components of a good life
so the bottom line message here and this
is one of the core messages of planetary
health is that we can't be healthy and
thrive as a species
without having a healthy thriving stable
planet
and if the planet is dysfunctional we
can't be very healthy either
but as i mentioned we are not in that
situation now each of the parameters
shown here has changed
relatively dramatically in the last
century or two and especially in the
last 50 or 70 years
such that we live on a different planet
than our grandparents inhabited
but it's important to understand as we
push for health and well-being for all
that it's not only these physical
processes that we have to contend with
we also face social and demographic
challenges such as a growing global
population an asian global population
and increasing globalization these green
lines here represent in the days before
covid daily airplane flights an
illustration of how closely knitted
together we are as a planet
we also face poverty
and related to that but distinct income
inequality and racism and discrimination
in far too many parts of the world
we also face
disinformation propelled by social media
we face increasing levels of populism in
the world and related to that the rise
of authoritarian governments in many
many countries
and we face biomedical challenges as
well of course there's the pandemic but
there's also the continued rise of
non-communicable diseases
and the rise of loneliness in the
decline in social capital and social
connectedness
all of these things affect our ability
to cope with and to manage the planetary
disruptions that i mentioned earlier
and of course as you can well imagine
these problems don't exist in isolation
they interact with each other that's
represented by this iconic picture of a
coveted warning sign
in california this past summer being
engulfed by a wildfire that was
potentially contributed to by climate
change so here you've got climate change
and a pandemic illness interacting with
each other to endanger people
so much so that these interactions are
probably best depicted by a picture like
this
illustrating the first law of ecology
that everything is connected to
everything this is the notion of a poly
crisis
now there's one more dimension of our
current situation that i'd like to
mention
and that is how fast things are changing
so let me show you a couple of slides of
the pace of change
this is a picture of biodiversity loss
of vertebrate species that are going
extinct what i want you to notice
is how steeply this line is increasing
the rate of extinction is increasing and
these are just for vertebrates here when
it comes to insects the extinction rate
is even higher about seven or eight
times higher an extinction rate for
insects as we have for vertebrates
here's a picture of
ice melting in antarctica and you can
see that the sea ice loss is
accelerating
here's a picture of glacier loss and as
you can see it is accelerating rapidly
as well
here's a picture of weather-related
catastrophes rapidly accelerating
so all of the changes that i mentioned
or almost all of them are not only
progressing but the pace of change is
increasing
as that happens it takes us closer and
closer to the possibility of tipping
points the tipping point is an
irreversible system change that shifts
the state of the world and that could be
for example the
slowing or stopping of the atlantic
circulation which maintains climate in
much of the northern hemisphere it could
be the loss of the greenland ice sheet
and these things of course interact with
each other
the last
mention of timing that i'd like to offer
you is illustrated by this picture this
is a bit of a complicated picture
this is a picture of various pathways if
we are to limit global warming to one
and a half degrees each pathway is a
colored line and it differs according to
assumptions that we make about the
sensitivity of earth systems to
greenhouse gases
and the pace of human responses
but what i want you to notice is that
every one of these pathways that gets us
to limiting warning to 1.5 degrees
begins with a downturn in our greenhouse
gas emissions right about here
in fact every successful pathway
contemplates that we would cut our
greenhouse gas emissions in half by 2030
and get to net zero emissions by 2050
but
that's not the path we're on at the
moment
co2 emissions continue to rise
they fell a little bit with covid and
are expected to bounce back as we emerge
from the pandemic
so
a complex set of global changes that
threaten human health and well-being and
the stability of the way we live
these changes are accelerating
we haven't yet triggered the responses
that we need to trigger and those of us
in the health sciences know that there
is a word for this
and that word is an emergency
but one of the responses to this
emergency has been the growth of a field
called planetary health
it emerged with a manifesto published in
the lancet in 2014
the rockefeller lancet commission on
planetary health published its big
report in 2015 which kind of
launched the field
there was a planetary health alliance
established in 2016
academic units around the world london
sao paulo and elsewhere over the next
few years
and now as aaron was kind enough to
mention we have a couple of textbooks in
the field i was honored to be a
contributor to both of these
and so this marks the emergence of a
field
planetary health is defined in
relatively complex ways but the simplest
definition is shown here
simply put planetary health is the
health of human civilization in the
state of natural systems on which it
depends
so let's work some examples now i want
to pick examples that are very quotidian
examples from our daily lives the energy
we use the stuff we make and the food we
eat and illustrate for you how a
planetary health approach would help us
sort through
uh tackle problems and protect human
health and well-being
now in the energy arena the most obvious
example to talk about is climate change
you all know a lot about climate change
you know that with the increases in the
use of energy that i showed you earlier
since it comes from burning fossil fuels
that releases carbon dioxide you all
know that the level of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere has increased over recent
years
and you all know that that leads to
impacts on human health through a
variety of pathways as shown here
i actually don't want to talk about
climate change and i don't want to talk
about climate change because i assume
that everybody on this call knows a fair
amount about the impacts of climate on
health
and i want to make the point that even
if we didn't have a changing climate the
planetary health framework would still
be very useful to us and so i want to
use other examples to illustrate that
but i do want to linger on climate
change for just a moment to make one
point and that point is shown here
this is a graph of household income in
the u.s from the low-income households
to the high-income households
and the carbon footprint shown on the
y-axis
what i want you to see here is that the
carbon footprint for those of us who are
wealthy
is much much higher than the carbon
footprint of the low-income households
if you deconstruct that carbon footprint
it can be attributed to food and to
housing
and to even the clothing we wear and to
the way we travel and to the services we
use
the wealthy people are responsible for a
much bigger share of greenhouse gas
emissions than the not so wealthy people
and that's true on a global scale as
well this is a graph of the world's
population with the poorest 50 percent
here and the richest 10 percent up at
the top
what you can see is that the richest 10
percent of the world's population is
responsible for almost half of
greenhouse gas emissions and the poorest
50 percent for only 10 percent of those
emissions so again the same pattern the
wealthy are creating much more of the
problem than the poor
but
the impacts
are felt in completely different ways
here is a map of carbon emissions
scaling countries by their cumulative
emissions so you see a very large
bloviated united states a very large
bloviated europe and a tiny little
vestigial africa and south asia
but when it comes to the impacts of
climate change the pattern is the
reverse
few impacts on tiny little u.s and
europe very large impacts on africa and
south asia where people are so
unfortunate
so this is a core planetary health
principle the principle of equity that
those of us who are fortunate have
caused a lot of the problem
and we need to be thinking very hard
about protecting and elevating
people who are less fortunate and
achieving more equity as we develop
solutions
the energy example that i do want to
linger on for a moment is the question
of dams
now what do we think about dams well if
we look at the greenhouse gas emissions
of various sources of electricity you
can see here that coal is quite high oil
is quite high natural gas is lower but
still quite high
and if you look over to the right
hydroelectricity is one of the least
greenhouse gas emitting ways to make
electricity and that's a terrific thing
i'm proud to tell you that in my part of
the world in the pacific northwest the
columbia river basin is almost
completely built out with these many
dams that you see represented by red and
yellow dots
and that's why our electricity in
washington state where i live is
two-thirds hydro much of the rest is
renewables of other forms such as wind
so we have a very low carbon footprint
and hydro helps a lot with that
dams are being built at a very fast clip
there are almost 3 million dams in the
world most of those are for
flooding control and for irrigation but
3 500 of them are hydroelectric dams and
another 3 700 are planned or under
construction as you can see here
this is asia here's latin america the
purple dots represent dams that are
operating the red dots or dams that are
planned and the yellow dots or dams that
are under construction so we're seeing a
growth in hydroelectric energy
now that has human implications this is
the three gorgeous dam in china which
was completed in 2006 it's a very big
dam
it displaced over a million people it
obliterated 13 cities in 140 towns and
over 1300 villages and that was well
documented to cause large levels of
stress of mental health problems of
upending people's lives and that's just
one example of the adverse impacts of
dams in fact dams represent an important
planetary health principle and that's
the principle of complex tradeoffs
the benefits are many as you can see
here clean electricity a dependable
water supply irrigation flood control
and recreation
but
dams threaten health and well-being in
several ways they alter river ecology
they alter the fluxes of various
elements they emit methane
and there are direct risks one of which
we'll come back to in just a minute of
infectious disease of population
displacement and of dam collapse in case
of disaster
dams also illustrate another planetary
health principle as shown here
each of these benefits of dams
is expected to vary with climate change
in fact in my part of the world the
amount of electricity we were able to
get from dams declined by about 10
percent over the last couple of years
with dry weather
because the flow of water the amount of
snow melt that we had available in the
spring and early summer declined and
that meant less water moving through the
dams and giving us electricity
as we get changes in hydrology changes
in rainfall patterns declining snow melt
we will see a decreasing function of
many dams
the principle here is that any of the
big issues we tackle need to be thought
about not just in the present tense but
also in the future tense we need to
think ahead
5 10 20 decades because we know that we
live on a rapidly changing planet
next example i want to talk about
regards to stuff we use and i'm going to
talk about plastic wherever you are now
sitting in your office in your bedroom
outside on the porch if you look around
i'll wager that you will see some
plastic it's a ubiquitous part of our
lives
now plastic as you know consists of
polymers of various simple molecules be
it ethylene or propylene or styrene and
plastic is used in a great many parts of
our lives
plastic is interesting in that it is
part of the great acceleration it
essentially didn't exist before the mid
20th century and plastic production has
ramped up rapidly since then it now
exceeds 320 million metric tons per year
globally
or about 40 kilograms for every man
woman and child on earth
that means that on average each of us
now alive will account for over 2 800
kilograms of plastic production over our
lifespan
or 30 or 40 times our body weight
that plastic goes for packaging for
consumer items for construction
automotive and other uses as you see
here
not only that plastic production is
increasing as the world becomes more and
more prosperous it's expected to double
or triple or more in coming years so
plastic is a growing thing
now plastic lasts a long time
if the workers who had built the great
wall of china or machu picchu or the taj
mahal five or six centuries ago had
sipped water from plastic bottles during
their breaks from work
those plastic bottles would likely still
exist
now that matters what happens to the
discarded plastic is consequential by
one estimate for every human being now
alive
somewhere in the world there is about
one metric ton of plastic
some of it's in use but over half of it
is waste
where does the waste go
well some of it's in landfills
some of it's in waterways a common and
heartbreaking site in many of the
world's major cities
plastic generally floats so it travels
with currents and accumulates in eddies
forming patches that can be as large and
imposing as islands
from streams rivers and harbors the
waste winds its way to oceans an
estimated 5 to 13 million metric tons
each year
driven by wind and currents the plastic
seems to go everywhere
making what seems a local problem a
global problem
plastic has been found in the deepest
ocean trenches in arctic ice in
mongolian mountain lakes on remote
island shores
the world's ocean systems tend to
concentrate waste in the five great
ocean gyres that you see shown on this
map
interestingly the highest concentration
of plastic debris ever measured on a
beach
was on remote henderson island on the
western edge of the south pacific gyre 5
000 kilometers from the nearest human
habitation
now plastic waste comes in many
categories from macro plastics like the
six-pack holder that
literally shaped the life of this
unfortunate turtle
all the way down to micro and nano
plastics some of which are manufactured
that way such as the microfibers in our
clothing some of which breaks down from
larger plastics into smaller plastics
some of that plastic enters the food
chain
we know that sea birds eat plastics
mistaking them for food and an estimated
90 percent of sea birds like this
albatross now have plastic in their
bodies but what's even more interesting
perhaps is the way plastics the micro
nanoplastics get into the food web
this is a picture of the uptake of
polystyrene beads by zooplankton you can
see them fluorescing green here in these
pictures
and as you might imagine here's the
complex food web the nanoplastics and
the micro plastics are taken up by very
small critters
which are eaten by me larger critters
which written by larger critters still
eventually reaching the top predators
like this orca were like this human
being
we've now seen more and more studies
like this one this is a study of fish
and shellfish bought in markets in
indonesia and california
to check for the presence of plastics
in over a quarter of the individual fish
that were sampled and in half the
species that were sampled in both
countries
plastic was found when we eat fish
we eat plastic
and it's not just fish as you can see
here this is a sampling of recent
studies whether it's sea salt or honey
or beer
three of the basic food groups right
there many kinds of seafood plastic is
found routinely when it is looked for
and of course if you follow that right
through the pipeline
it is in human feces as well in the one
small study that has been conducted so
plastics are ubiquitous in our food
supply
but plastic isn't just plastic and
that's one of the reasons for health
concern on average ninety-three percent
of plastic is the polymer itself but
seven percent is additives plasticizers
fillers flame retardants and so on not
only that plastic is a really good
surface for absorbing synthetic organic
chemicals some of these chemicals such
as polychlorinated biphenyls are very
persistent in the environment
hence the term persistent organic
pollutants
and many of them are biologically active
in fact environmental loading with
chemicals such as these pops persistent
organic pollutants is a hallmark of the
anthropocene
and ingestion isn't the only way that
these plastics get into our bodies
the consumption study that shows that
plastic is found in so many foods
also has shown
that the mass of inhaled microplastics
can equal or exceed the amount we ingest
this diagram is from a just published
paper that quantified the plastic con
ambient particulate matter in the air
pollution of china's pearl river delta
there was a substantial burden with
phthalate estrus being the major species
that was found in air pollution
now plastics together with their fellow
travelers persistent organic pollutants
pops travel the concept of
biogeochemical cycles that used to apply
to natural things like carbon water
phosphorus nitrogen might also be
applied now in the anthropocene to pops
mops are fat soluble
they bioconcentrate within the fat of
organisms such as fish cattle and polar
bears they're biomagnified as they move
from lower to higher trophic levels in
food webs
and they spread
fear and oceanic transport as shown here
even in ecosystems such as the arctic
far from where they were ever produced
or used at any kind of scale
one recent study of inuit people in the
canadian arctic found that those with
the highest blood levels of pcbs were
two to four times more likely to have
diabetes than people with the lowest
levels
so the planetary health lesson here is
that we can change
the chemical composition of our planet
and we can do that in global ways even
problems that seem localized can be
global problems
there's another planetary health lesson
and it's a good one
we can make change this is a map of
where plastic bags have been banned or
taxed around the world
the red means banning and the green
means taxing and the brown is a partial
ban or tax what you can see is that many
countries have stepped up to make a
change and to respond and interestingly
many of those countries are in the
global south there are low-income
countries which are doing fine making do
without plastic bags and showing
leadership
here in our country
change is also possible the blue states
are the states where there are bans on
plastic bags and the light blue states
are fees or taxes
but another lesson of planetary health
is that there is a lot of resistance to
change these green states are states
where
there are bans on banning plastic that
is local ordinances that want to ban
plastic bags have been preempted by
state law
this is a campaign driven by a lobbying
group called the american progressive
bag alliance
representing the plastic bag industry
it's an independent division of the
plastics industry association so there
are lots of vested interests maintaining
the status quo that's an important
reality of the anthropocene
the almost last example i want to show
you
is going to turn to food and i want to
talk about nuts
now nuts are an interesting kind of food
if there are any nutritionists in the
audience you'll know that nuts are
actually very good for human health
in fact we have quite a large literature
detailing the nutritional benefits of
nuts almonds and cardiovascular health
walnuts are good for the microbiome
pecans are good to reduce cardio
metabolic risk
and if you talk to your nutritional
friends they'll tell you we should all
be eating more nuts
in fact in the nutritional world lots of
interesting questions arise about nuts
what components of nuts promote health
that can we make healthier nuts how much
should we eat of nuts every day how do
we get people to eat more nuts
but in planetary health terms i would
argue that there is one question about
nuts that we don't ask or hear very much
at all where do nuts come from
so we need to think upstream this is
part of planetary hill thinking well we
all know where nuts come from they come
from the convenience store they're in
little plastic bags and you buy them and
you can just eat them as a snack
but if you go upstream from there
it turns out that nuts come from
beautiful orchards like this almond
orchard or this walnut orchard
where are those orchards
well these two pie charts show where
nuts are produced globally in this case
almonds and walnuts you can see that
almonds are produced almost uh well
better than three quarters of the
world's supply in the united states
walnuts are about half from china and
about a third from the united states
within the united states if we look to
see where the nuts come from they come
almost exclusively from california
which has the
lion's share of nut production in this
country
now
that's interesting what do we know about
california agriculture and the
appropriateness of growing nuts in
california
well
this is a picture of the water footprint
of various foods and you can see that
next to beef
the most water thirsty food to produce
on a liters per kilogram basis is nuts
nuts take a lot of water to grow
what do we know about water in
california
well we know that the last decade has
been a hugely challenging time for
california because of a prolonged
drought
in fact if you were just beginning from
scratch this might be one of the last
places you would think about growing
nuts right there along with phoenix
arizona it's not the place you would
choose to put a water hungry crop
not only that the forecast for coming
decades under climate change
indicate more chaotic weather extremes
more severe droughts and less water from
snowmelt so the situation doesn't look
like it's going to get much better
anytime soon
to here we have a collision of
nutritional advice with environmental
stewardship and that raises questions
such as is a cardioprotective diet
sustainable
we need to look at the environmental
aspects of the foods that we eat as well
as of many aspects of our lives
because the complex system analysis we
have to do
may lead us to slightly different
conclusions than simply asking are nuts
good for health
well i've laid out some pretty
challenging and even grim news for you
and you must feel a little bit
of despair right now it's actually
pretty common to feel despair when you
think about these planetary challenges
but there are great solutions in hand
and the last example i want to show you
it illustrates a great solution
this is the diama dam along the senegal
river not a major dam it's only 18
meters high
but it helps to store water
and support irrigation in surrounding
communities in senegal
18 meters is high enough to keep the
tide from pushing brackish water up the
river
so after the dam was built it created an
ideal freshwater habitat for snails
now you might recall that snails form
part of the life cycle of the
schistosoma trematode or fluke which is
the cause of schistosomiasis
sure enough after the dam was built in
1986
a snails proliferated along the river
and a fierce outbreak of schistosomiasis
followed
but a win-win ecological solution
emerged
that solution was prawns
this is a brilliant series of papers the
kind of thing that planetary health
research yields
showing that when the river was stocked
with prawns
which are predators of snails a lot of
good things happened
one was a dramatic reduction in
schistosomiasis
improvements in health another was an
improvement in health and well-being of
people living along the river because
they gained a dietary protein source
and a cash crop in the prawns
so the solutions that emerge from fusing
biomedical ecological sociocultural and
economic thinking can be truly inspiring
i want to close now by turning to the
subject of hope this is a picture of
despair and in fact the planetary
changes that i described are grim
i recently spoke about climate change to
a university class and i asked how many
had confronted despair in considering
the issue of climate change
every hand went up
no surprise despair is an occupational
hazard for anybody who considers
contemporary planetary change
but we need to fight despair
it's immobilizing it's painful and it
doesn't accomplish anything at a moment
when we have to be about accomplishing a
lot we need to embrace hope ourselves
and we need to inspire hope in other
people
fortunately there's plenty of basis for
hope and it's with that that i'd like to
close
i'm going to show you quickly eight
reasons that i think hope is not only
justified but imperative and here they
are
first
co-benefits now this is a good story
what we have to do to shift to a green
sustainable economy and to make the
world the place that will last for our
grandchildren
shown here clean energy well-designed
cities that include
alternatives to motor vehicles plenty of
green space
ecologically designed low-energy
buildings and so on healthy diets
meaning a shift away from
uh resource-intensive meats toward diets
that are a little heavier and plants
green chemistry so that we're not
putting persistent organic pollutants
into the environment
what if we line those up alongside some
of the major public health goals we have
less heart disease lung disease and
cancer better mental health
less infectious disease and fewer
injuries healthier child development
well here's the good news
we have very solid evidence that clean
energy delivers many of those public
health goals
much of that improvement is through
cleaner air but there are other pathways
as well each of them very solidly
supported by evidence
we have very solid evidence that
well-designed cities
deliver those health benefits as well
we have very solid evidence that healthy
diets deliver many of those health
benefits
and that green chemistry delivers many
of those health benefits
so the transition to a green sustainable
economy tackling these planetary health
challenges is not a story of deprivation
and sacrifice it's actually a story of
better healthier lives and that's good
news reason for hope
second the technology is advancing here
are just two examples
batteries are getting better and better
when we have good batteries we can
facilitate the shift from fossil fuel
electricity to renewable electricity
batteries providing the electricity at
times when those sources aren't
delivering
even such difficult sectors as aerospace
are seeing
massive leaps forward with aviation fuel
that may be sustainably produced as well
technology is advancing
economics are improving the costs of
renewable energy have tumbled faster
than anybody would have predicted such
that in almost every part of the world
now solar and wind are cheaper than
fossil electricity
policy is maturing many many countries
have made commitments to going to net
zero
by 2050 sometimes even sooner than that
suriname and bhutan are there already a
number of other countries have
legislated a net zero commitment and
targets are under active discussion in
99 additional countries they're being
discussed today at president biden
summit and they'll be discussed in
glasgow at the next conference of the
parties of the unf triple c
not only at the national level but at
the sub-national level cities are
competing with each other to be the
first city to go green and to go net
zero
we're seeing really interesting
legislative initiatives here in the us
as the fossil fuel infrastructure that
you see here gets banned in place after
place
and as
infrastructure for the new green economy
is advanced by cities that are forward
thinking
we are seeing activism blossoming as
exemplified by some of the pictures
shown here and that activism in turn
motivates and pushes policy makers
to pass the policies that we need
public opinion is shifting this is a
picture of the proportion of americans
who are extremely or very sure that
global warming is happening
denialism is falling and belief in the
problem is rising
in fact here's an interesting little
snippet of information on public opinion
this was exit polling by fox news on
election day
this past november
70 percent of the voters surveyed by fox
news favor increased government spending
on green and renewable energy so public
opinion is coming along
culture change is possible here i've
found some posters from the second world
war
what you see is that the public was
urged to use less electricity
to use less
food and especially less meat
to buy local
don't buy things you don't need don't
drive if you don't need to
and you know what
americans
met that challenge and made those
changes and did it willingly for the
greater good
that kind of thing is possible so we
don't need to be cynical about that
results are emerging this is a picture
of the growth of renewable energy this
is hydro in blue this is wind in red
other renewables up above it is growing
very very fast
in fact a big milestone was that last
year renewables pulled ahead of coal so
change is happening
even in the private sector we're seeing
enormous leadership this is the
automotive sector and car companies are
competing with each other now to be the
first ones to go all electric and to
provide us with the best choices of
electric vehicles
which are much more
environment-friendly climate-friendly
than our our traditional internal
combustion engines
so for all these reasons
there's no need to despair there's
plenty of reason for hope
well i've tried to give you a quick
run-through of the concept of planetary
health the health of human civilization
and the state of the natural systems on
which it depends
a framework for doing science and for
developing solutions that is people
centered that is systems based that
faces upstream and looks at root causes
that is committed to equity
that is oriented toward the future
that is solutions driven and that
inspires hope i want to thank you very
much for your attention i wish you all a
happy earth day and i look forward to
the q a
thank you so much um dr pumpkin that was
very thought provoking i echo a comment
from our audience
very thoughtful booking topic i will
always think twice now when uh choosing
nuts
or bother an airplane
which is the standard fare
um
there are a couple questions but i'll
consolidate into one
um when you think of sustainability you
think of the next electric cars there's
battery operated that's how i
would like your thoughts on the
sustainability of those new technologies
uh because of resources taken uh to
create those the batteries and then
recycling
well you know
a great question and i you know nothing
is perfect
life poses us with a lot of trade-offs
and one of the points i tried to make
with dams which are a great technology
is that even dams have their downsides
so electric vehicles have they're much
better in terms of greenhouse gas
emissions than internal combustion but
they're not perfect
so i think moving toward walking and
cycling
moving toward a greater use of transit
uh developing
uh well the technology that we're all
using now
the
telecommunications means that
telecommuting can become more and more
of a reality as we emerge from
and that means reducing travel demand
so there are many dimensions to a
complex problem
and transportation is a great example
we are going to have to continue to use
resources to travel there's no way
around that but if we think in a
multi-dimensional way
and if we tally the environmental
benefits and the health benefits of each
of the possible solutions we can
optimize the answers we come up with
what i'd recommend to everybody is you
know
if you have an internal combustion
engine vehicle think about an electric
one if you have an electric vehicle
think about a bicycle
you have a bicycle think about walking
because walking and cycling are going to
be healthier for you than driving any
kind of vehicle and if you have transit
and can use that
that's great it's one of the lowest
carbon footprints and by the way the
walking to and from a transit stop
whether it's light rail or a bus
builds in daily physical activity to
your life so the benefits we get from
that cleaner air physical activity
fewer car crashes less noise in our
cities and towns
multiple health benefits and so it's one
of those many places where
as we make the best decisions we can
knowing that no decision's perfect we
can optimize a lot of good outcomes
excellent
um is with the last amount of time that
we have with you i would like to ask
your
ideas we're a research institution many
of our attendees are scientists what do
you see as the
next
and the biggest research questions and
areas that we need to move forward on
well i think we need to understand
health threats
and so this is if you will the diagnosis
part of the issue
how will climate change reduce the
nutrient content of foods
how will rising sea levels affect
habitability of cities
many many questions we know a lot about
the impacts of global environmental
change but there's a lot we need to know
second we need research on solutions so
what sorts of crops will be most viable
in the world
50 years from now
most nutritious most economical to grow
what sorts of heat wave preparedness
plans are going to be most effective at
protecting people from the impacts of
heat so there's a whole
science we might call solutionology
developing solutions to protect people
from the hazards that we document
with research
third
is co-benefits so as we do things like
change our transportation system and
change our energy system we need to
understand
which ways of doing that are as health
promoting as possible
but that means linking health research
with research in energy transportation
agriculture and so on
so that developing environmentally
friendly ways to do all those things
also develops healthy ways to do those
things
we need a lot of social science research
how do we communicate these issues to
the public
how do we change policy
why is there a no do gap why do we know
many of the things we need to do but we
don't do them and how do we overcome any
of those
social and political barriers
across all of that research we need to
be very multi-disciplinary and that
means for those of you who train
students
don't just train them in toxicology but
do a little ecological thinking do a
little geographic thinking and blend all
of that
and i will be hearing from niehs in the
next session you know one of the very
promising things is that we're seeing
more and more move toward
interdisciplinarity
and synthetic science
through funders such as niehs
excellent um well i in the audience want
to thank you immensely uh for your
your deep dive into the issues that we
are facing but also the hopefulness that
you've brought to this conversation that
we can make change so
thank you thank you so much thank you
very much for the opportunity
fantastic
excellent
so moving on in our on our program
we wanted uh to highlight environmental
health uh disparities and environmental
justice issues that are facing um our
nation and our region and also in the
local setting
and uh to facilitate and moderate our
our next session which is a panel of
wonderful speakers um dr danielle
stephens
is going to be the moderator so i'll
introduce her
and then turn it over to her in the
esteems panel
uh dr stephen watkins is a she received
a phd in counseling psychology from the
university of kentucky she also has her
master's in clinical psych
from spaulding university
she is now the assistant vice president
for research and diversity and inclusion
here at uk and she leaves our unite
research priority area she has been
funded by nih for decades
and has research focusing on health
disparities and barriers to service and
utilization among african-american
populations
so danielle we are very glad to have you
as part of this event
and the the panel of yours
[Music]
good afternoon everyone thank you so
much for joining us
i have the pleasure to introduce our
three panelists
for this afternoon panel session
i will start with our first panelist
heather henry heather henry is a program
officer with the superfund research
program at the national institute of
environmental health science
located in the research triangle park in
north carolina
at nieh heather manages
research grant programs
including university grants and small
business grants with topics ranging from
toxicology
environmental cleanups community
engagement
covet 19 and disaster response research
heather is a member of the niehs
environmental health disparities and
environmental justice faculty and is
involved in several efforts to promote
diversity equity and inclusion at niehs
we are so fortunate to have heather this
afternoon
thank you and i want to introduce
heather
thank you danielle and thank you so much
aaron for the invitation to
talk here today
and very much enjoyed the prior
presentation by dr frumpkin
i'm going to be talking about the
national perspective or a national
perspective regarding environmental
health disparities
and
i'm going to be taking an attack talking
about research legislation as well as
coordination
so i thought i'd start out with some
definitions
a health disparity is a health
difference closely linked to social
economic
and or environmental disadvantages so
when it comes to an environmental health
disparity these are stress these are
disparities related from
resulting from stressors
including environmental exposures
exposures that might be related to
natural or man-made disasters
and these disparities amplify or
increase existing health disparities in
vulnerable communities
and by vulnerable communities uh we tend
to notice that these are communities
experiencing lower ses
closer to pollution limited health care
maybe experiencing a lifetime burden of
multiple exposures as well as limited
literacy
environmental justice goes alongside
with environmental health disparity and
is sort of an aspirational goal
to achieve a fair treatment and
meaningful involvement of people
regardless of race color national origin
or income with respect to the
development implementation and
enforcement of environmental laws
regulation and policies
i think it's important to note that
when it comes to environmental health
disparities a majority falls on
low-income minority tribal and
indigenous communities they're more
likely to be
varying the hazard the environmental
insults that are involved with
environmental health disparities
so i'm going to start
by giving a context of what's happening
at niehs
we're not the only institute from the
national institutes of health that uh is
working on environmental health
disparities
but certainly we um the work that is
being done at niehs is illustrative of
other efforts
um and it's a very important aspect of
our own strategic plan to uncover and
understand
um these social determinants of health
as well as promote environmental justice
so i'll start with research that's
happening at niehs
those of you may know we're located in
national we're located in research
triangle park north carolina
and we have several scientists
working
working there in laboratories and
running contracts
as it pertains to environmental health
disparities
the national toxicology program
does several toxicity testing related to
chemicals that might be associated with
ethnic personal care products
diseases that are more common among
minorities or pesticides and migrant
workers we have an active epidemiology
group
working in several communities
looking at environmental justice issues
and we also sponsor community forums
with uh with our director rick wojcik
and then have coordination efforts for
groups that relate to environmental
health disparities such as disaster
research as well as environmental
global health
and niehs is also involved with covid
activities that are at the nih level
and as it relates to
environmental health disparities there
are two programs that work directly with
underserved populations
niehs has a management role for some of
those
radx up is a testing strategy for
underserved populations and radix rad is
a water wastewater surveillance
means to assess coded in communities
but i'm going to turn gears now and talk
more about the work that niehs is
funding and we have a program
for environmental health disparities
that look at basic epidemiological as
well as social scientific factors that
explain the burden of disease in
lower socioeconomic populations
partnerships for environmental public
health
has a research to action program this is
this highlights
the importance of community engaged
research
the worker training program provides
work skills to impacted communities
the superfund research program is an
example of the multi-disciplinary
research that dr trumpkin was talking
about and
has a systems approach to problem
solving
and then lastly we have a time sensitive
research grant program
which enables small group small grants
encouraging partnerships between
researchers and disaster affected
communities many of whom are some of the
vulnerable communities that i was
mentioning previously
so just to give an example of one of the
environmental health disparities
research centers
this feature is on madres which is a
maternal
maternal development risk from
environmental and social stressors the
center is out of the university of
southern california and focuses in on
low-income hispanic women in los angeles
area
and i just want to point out some recent
work that they've done
mapping coded case rates pollution and
public transit and housing density and
uh
just to make one little take-home
message here that um this this type of
work this type of interaction with
communities has really enabled um
the
community outreach uh to let to let the
madras families know more about kovid's
susceptibility
and uh the research to action again this
is a program that really focuses in on
community partnerships and i'm
mentioning just two of them here
they're both relevant to kentucky
the mountain air project focuses on
disparities in appalachian communities
with regard to respiratory health and a
recent program
is one looking at diverse is looking at
disinfection byproducts also in the
appalachian area
um and again in terms of another
take-home message just how important it
is uh to engage communities in research
especially the type of research that
niehs is doing um not only does this
help build capacity but you know it
there is evidence that it improves
intervention success
uh and i want to point out that those
partnerships in environmental public
health also has a vibrant podcast system
and they had a recent feature on another
kentucky example this is out of
louisville the green heart study um
looks to examine the impacts of green
neighborhoods on heart health
and
this type of
intervention i think also points to
another take-home message it's just
sustainable solutions so this this work
is based on rigorous science uh the
solution itself really gives back to the
community through creating additional
green space
and talking about giving back to the
community the worker education and
training program has had a long-standing
interaction of with in in training uh
low-income uh minority communities who
are in impact who are in communities
that are impacted by hazardous
substances so through
providing job training it has really
raised the capacity not only of
individuals but also their families by
giving them additional livelihoods
um the
recent work that has uh has been
undertaken by the worker training
program is to fund specifically um
covid19
uh essential worker training
um
and so uh just to again make another
take-home message about job training and
how this um activity not only advances
cleanup but also improves of the
livelihood of individuals and families
and uh the superfund research program
this is the program
for which i i am a part and uh as
mentioned before this is a highly
multi-disciplinary research program it
has biomedical environmental engineering
research a research translation
community engagement
a very important cross-sectoral training
so
training the next generation to to know
how to um converse with
many different sectors
and then data transparency and
integration is also an important part
of these centers
so a lot going on in these centers and
maybe a point i just wanted to make
relevant to environmental health
disparities and environmental justice is
something that the srp is moving towards
as part of our new strategic plan um
that's a systems approach and a systems
approach at its best
means inviting multiple perspectives to
the table to understand a full system in
which a problem exists
allowing you to to possibly find
many solutions
in multiple sectors
and
um
you know
taking the point home just a little bit
more
you know being a part of the national
institute of health of course we're very
interested in health disparities and
biomedical issues and dysfunctions um
and in some cases uh solutions are found
through biomedical interventions um such
as pharmaceuticals but you know in many
cases um you know we're finding that the
it's not always a biomedical solution
there may be several non-biomedical
solutions
and um i don't think the superfund
research program is um the only one
doing this i think the
groups that i've talked about prior to
this are also established showing how um
sustainable solutions are can be really
uh broad for improving health um again
having interventions that are based on
science
identifying multiple ways to reduce
exposures
that allows you to tailor
interventions to the community make sure
that it is
it is in keeping with economic and
other other practical
concerns
um and as as mentioned in the prior
presentation um you can you can address
one problem by
uh bringing bringing a solution to other
problems so you can give back to the
community and in some cases address
other issues of inequity
i just briefly wanted to touch on some
ongoing work within the centers
um and make the point about how
important it is to communicate risk and
make informed decision
um
you know
there there's work at the university of
kentucky on diet and health
northeastern university is working with
population puerto rico about risk
uncertainty
for several contaminants that are found
in in the study population
water testing water treatment and
healthy fishing are also
a ways that our grantees are bringing
science and helping
individuals make personal choices to
reduce exposures
and then
stepping onto a larger scale communities
making informed decisions um having
communities at the table for remediation
decisions is very important and the role
of our university centers to help broker
and understanding of the implications of
some remediation efforts such as pfas
incineration and dredging
this is really important to communities
to to feel confident that
the solution is not causing additional
problems to their to their
community
and
uh with climate and extreme weather
events uh there there's also tremendous
opportunity
to understand and try to suggest
better urban planning
to prevent some of the
vulnerabilities of communities who are
who are impacted by extreme weather
events
and that's a good segue to talking about
other national efforts on the horizon uh
being that climate change the executive
order recently
released has several provisions for
environmental justice
so justice 40 is an initiative
originating from a grassroots effort but
now as a part of the executive order
that calls for an investment of 40 of
federal
activities for climate change to go to
disadvantaged communities
in addition uh they'll be ramping up
screening mapping screening tools to
make it
easier to identify vulnerable
communities in a climate and
environmental justice perspective and uh
the executive or order also calls for
the establishment of a white house
environmental justice advisory committee
uh their next meeting is april 28th um
so might be interesting for those who
attend of course it's virtual and
you're able to participate that way
and also the covid stimulus package
included 100 million in funding for
environmental justice grants as well as
a
grant to state and local governments to
reduce air pollution in marginalized
communities
i just want to talk about uh the
department of health and human services
a couple of other activities the atsdr
just released a community stress
resource center and this is a tool for
helping communities understand how they
can reduce stress and build resilience
especially as it relates to
environmental contamination
um also want to mention healthy people
2020 this is an excellent resource for
understanding health disparities uh
through time um it pulls together
resources from several databases so you
can actually see and measure how
ethnicity and several other
socioeconomic factors impact
a disease outcome
and related to that is healthy people
2030 which sets goals for the future for
reducing health disparities and among
those
goals are several that relate directly
to environmental health disparities
here's an example of
homes with safe water
uh lots going on in the federal level
and so coordination is very important
and the inter-agency working group on
environmental justice is is that group
that helps pull together and coordinate
activities that are happening
great resource for funding opportunities
and events related to environmental
justice and more recently they held a
series of town halls on covet and
natural disasters and underserved
communities and i believe the report is
due out
in august
epa has several environmental justice
resources uh they they award grants they
have a screening tool uh that i
mentioned previously it's gonna be a
part of the climate change package
and then they also have reports on
successes in ej communities
and finally the
national environmental justice advisory
council is a is a group that informs the
epa and it's coordinated by them and
they also have public meetings
so that was a real whirlwind of national
activities uh
national institute environmental health
sciences i think gives an it gives an
idea of the type of work that is ongoing
in the federal government
basic to apply data-driven research
community-based interventions building
capacity creating value within a
community and taking a systems approach
to solving problems
white house initiatives as well as
accompanying legislation i think is an
indication that we'll be seeing
more and more of an emphasis on
environmental health disparities and
environmental justice
and with that this builds on several
excellent resources and products out of
the department of health and human
services as well as the environmental
protection agency
um and then again just to point back to
that kind of overarching idea that you
know
we we can look towards sustainable
solutions to really improve the health
in vulnerable communities
not only based on understanding of
exposures but helping people under make
good personal choices helping
communities make good decisions about
remediation and urban planning and then
also be ready for
those surprise events that come up that
we don't expect like code vid19 and
other climate change issues
and so with that um i want to point to
you towards a
request for information that is out and
due tomorrow for the niehs inviting
comments and suggestions to advance and
strengthen racial equity diversity and
inclusion in the biomedical research
workforce and advanced health
disparities and health equity research i
also have posted on the this webinar
format a document that has a list of
funding opportunities and other
resources
some of which are listed here
and so i'd like to thank you as an
audience thank the organizers and a big
thanks to the real environmental health
disparity and environmental justice
experts at niehs who provided some help
to me
in putting this live together so thank
you back to you danielle
thank you so much heather for presenting
if you all could
keep your questions to the end and we're
going to present those questions to our
panelists
at the end of our last presentation so
please make sure you document your
questions in the q a box and i will be
revisiting that box at the end of our
panel
our second presenter
is amanda lefevre she is the deputy
commissioner of the department for
environmental protection
amanda serves as the deputy commissioner
and she previously served as the
director of the division of compliance
assistance
dca
she specializes in enhancing the
educational offerings in dca
and its programs which includes
compliance assistance
brownfields and the state's
environmental leadership program ky
excel
she serves as the chair of the
association of the state and territorial
solid waste management officials
brownfield focus group and the vice
chair of the
cercla
and brownsville subcommittee
amanda earned a bachelor's degree from
brexit university and a master's degree
in public administration from the
university of kentucky
amanda is a kentucky native originally
from falls rough kentucky
welcome amanda thank you
thank you so much and uh thank you for
having me here today uh with some such
wonderful speakers i'm honored and um i
just want to talk to you a little bit
today about uh our work with
environmental justice within the energy
and environment
cabinet and how we're trying to advance
environmental justice and community
engagement in order to you know help
address those uh disparities uh health
uh education and economic disparities
that we have in our communities so um
and my cat decided to take a you know
make an appearance today so apologies
um but
the thing about um ej is it's been a
part of my career within department for
environmental protection uh
since day one i've been with the with
the brownfields program most of my
career and if you're familiar with
brownfields that is
basically uh
working with communities to
assess and remediate
properties that are
contaminated or thought to be
contaminated so it's your urban blight
it's
your your rural areas where factories
have gone out it's
anything from dry cleaners to
mine scarred lands to
um you know
old factories and everything in between
so i've spent my uh career uh with
environmental justice because it goes
hand in hand uh with
um
brownfields and what we do because we
work directly with communities to
redevelop these properties and get them
back into reuse and that could be
anything from
an urban garden to a new business that
might provide jobs to social engagement
opportunities so um it can be whatever
that community wants and those are the
best redevelopments is when you can work
directly with community and it's you
know a community decision
of what that redevelopment is
so like i said i i've seen it all i've
worked in urban settings and rural
settings uh i've seen um
environmental justice uh you know in
terms of income and race um i i've
worked with coal communities with the
ends and flows of that industry uh as
well as other industries and you know if
you go to uh west side of louisville you
know you could see everything from
chemical factories to
everything else so um you know it's it's
a little bit of everything but the
impacts are are universal these are the
communities that have um issues with
safe and reliable work uh drinking water
i love martin county which we're working
with really closely right now uh places
have issues with access to food uh you
know
the local convenience store
should not be your your main uh source
of food when you get healthy fruits and
vegetables are are really uh what keeps
you healthy not only you know weight
wise but you know
cancer risks and everything like that um
you may not have access to health care
uh in these communities and and of
course there's fewer opportunities for
jobs so you can either you know move
move up move out or you know stay in
your neighborhood and you know advance
it so there's certainly challenges um
and so environmental justice is near and
dear to my heart and um uh you know with
my particular job at dep it's very part
and partial to it and um you know so
i've seen a little bit of everything but
i will tell you the one thing that
really um with an aha moment for me and
i think part of our challenge uh in dep
when we're talking about a new
environmental justice framework which
i'll get to here in a minute is giving
all of our employees that aha moment
that really brings it home to them but
early in my career um i was in the west
end of louisville at a community
health and safety fair and there was a
mascot there he's really really brightly
colored i've never seen him before you
know i grew up with louis the lightning
bug and um
you know
things like that but i never seen him
before i went over to the booth and he
was
wally the shelter in place turtle and he
teaches kids about sheltering in place
uh when there's some sort of
environmental um
emergency chemical spill something like
that
and um apparently he's he's originated
in a lot of the uh um
the bands where they're all the chemical
industries in the south but it was that
moment where you know even though i'd
grown up um you know somewhere between
middle class and poor and we had you
know
issues with you know bills and stuff
like that um i had never really had to
think about
that part of safety for me you know
what is it like growing up where that is
necessary where you have to have a
mascot to teach you
about sheltering in place um so that was
a weird little aha moment and it's
really stuck with me so uh but what we
really need is that for our other
cabinet employees because we have people
who um you know do permit applications
well that's mostly calculations and
things like that that may not be out in
about the public but
we want all of our employees to really
understand that everything that we do
with cabinet has some sort of
environmental health impact to someone
somewhere
so um
we are undergoing uh a process where we
are trying to really ramp up our
environmental justice efforts and how we
do business here within the within the
cabinet
so you know just a little background of
course you know
environmental justice is born of the
civil rights uh movement and
specifically there's some key events uh
the memphis sanitation strike
and the warren county pcb landfill that
really sort of kicked off the
environmental justice movement um and
you know that gave way to uh executive
order in 1994 under the clinton
administration that really um made you
know
may be fair treatment and medical
involvement of all people regardless of
race color national origin or income you
know part of the you know federal
landscape it's that environmental
justice um um you know goal there so um
and as
um you know as they've had to implement
it of course it applies to all the
federal programs
um
we are a designated
state you know we we
enforce these uh federal programs so the
clean air act safe drinking water act uh
rickra um all of that
we inherit from the federal agencies so
uh we
automatically
you have to you know implement and
internalize those environmental justice
uh frameworks and we have i mean we do
uh
um
open meetings and uh we do uh you know
uh public notification for permit
applications and things like that but
there's also that um you know
want to do more uh and i think
um
um
that you know the bashir administration
came in and i think one of the first few
things uh over the last summer um um is
we realized that we needed to
um look at that our environmental
justice framework and what we're doing
and uh we proposed a new one
so um this is something that we're
currently rolling out we actually just
started it but it's an effort to really
uh make our efforts more fruitful and be
more engaging with the public and with
our communities when it comes to
environmental decision making
so what we really want to do is raise
awareness of ej with an eec
some of those aha moments like i was
talking about
we want to really
work on effective community engagement
involvement
and not just passive notification
and and really work at communicating
information better to folks
there's a lot of agency program
evaluation that we need to do and
integration of ej into different
decision points and of course training
internally and externally and also using
some of the resources that were
mentioned in the last presentation um so
um you know there's there's lots of good
things out there for us to use and for
us to communicate with and for us to
decision make with so it's it's it's
really sort of internalizing all of that
stuff and making it part of our everyday
business practices
um so
the first thing i want to talk about is
a little bit is community engagement um
and
you know we as a regulatory agency um
we follow the letter of the law so
there's certain things we can and can't
do
but we do know that we can build
relationships with ej communities
so some of the things that we can't do
you know we can work with our partners
so we really want to work on
building relationships with those
organizations that are grassroots
that that really impact um
you know communities at the ground level
um we want to provide training and
educational materials to people
if
you've ever read an environmental permit
they're not so easy to read
um you know or you know sometimes
you know we have very very technical
documents so you know working on
materials so we meet people where they
are
and meet the needs of the audience
they're intended to inform
um
we're going to be looking at open
communication uh public notification and
involvement uh really doing effective
public meetings and hearings once again
meeting people where they are and their
needs
and adapt our methods of communication
to community needs
special populations
uh whether that is a hispanic community
or uh you know a
large bosnian community uh what what
type of language needs are there when we
communicate uh to two different audience
so so really just um
um looking at all of those things um
you know in terms of engagement
um
we also want to look at program
integration
so
um
program assessment um
i you know looking at everything that we
do
looking at our decision points where can
we really integrate uh
environmental justice as we go through
uh how do we implement that and you know
we have permitting programs we have
those corrective actions programs i
think dr dr henry
mentioned you know having people at the
table when we make remediation decisions
um of course brownfields
regulation development uh funding and
grants do we need a brownfield criteria
criteria uh in in our funding um
applications uh as a decision-making
tool and planning uh and i will say you
know and even in our inter our proactive
uh programs uh after this i'll be
talking about kentucky excel which is
our environmental leadership program how
do we challenge our members to
um
you know take on environmental justice
um
activities to really um
or projects to to help those movements
and communities
um and then there's internal and
external training uh
once again training our staff
on environmental justice what does that
mean how does your job
uh what is what you do how does it
impact people out across the state in
our communities um teaching about risk
communications how do you effectively
communicate risk um and then program
specific training but then all there's
also the external audiences
we have a lot of tools we need to do a
better job of teaching people how to
access and use the information that we
put out there um and then we need to
teach people about the permitting
process and how you do how do you get
actively involved in that how do you
read a permit how do you offer
comments on a permit um so there's all
sorts of opportunities
are opportunities for us to uh better
increase that engagement and increase
understanding between our audiences
and of course as before mentioned
there's some great tools out there for
us to use
as uh regulators um when we're talking
about assessing environmental justice
and and you know what it means in these
communities um so there's ej screen
which you mentioned you know of course
there's going to be enhancements so
already a great tool
um we have our toxic release inventory
community right now and then kentucky
has something called enviro health link
which is you know a lot of our
environmental health indicators
um so there's there's lots to be done
within eec and dep and we're going to be
looking at all of our programs looking
how we can educate staff and how to you
know
really
um
get people involved
and get our employees involved in that
environmental justice framework so um
i i hope a year out we have some really
really great things to
talk about in this i'm excited
and i think this is something that
uh can have uh great impacts for uh the
citizens of the commonwealth uh who
bear the undue burden of a lot of the uh
environmental decisions that have been
made over the years so uh with that i uh
there's my contact information should
you uh have any questions after this
please feel free to call uh contact me
so
thank you very much
thank you so much amanda we really
appreciate it
our next panelist is donovan taylor
he has completed a juris doctorate from
the university of kentucky college of
law and has management experience and
business and tax strategies
law and legal practice and community
organizing and development
he currently serves as the manager of
the plan room a non-profit business
accelerator focusing on capacity
building
for minority-owned contractors
subcontractors architects design firms
and suppliers
in the construction industry
donovan works with the chickasaw
neighborhood federation
rubbertown emergency act react and the
west louisville county community task
force to address area pollution concerns
thank you so much for joining us donovan
hello thank you good afternoon thanks
for having me today uh and i think to
our previous panelists as well uh for
our institutional on uh planetary impact
of pollution and our institutional
activity i'm going to bring you home to
uh the neighborhood and neighborhood
activity um
as it relates to environmental justice
and pollution
i am a resident and native of the
chickasaw neighborhood
which is located in western louisville
which is a unique and beautiful
neighborhood
i don't know what's going on
chickasaw was established in 1922 after
the establishment of the chickasaw park
that was designated for blacks in the
city of louisville
to chickasaw is a neighborhood made of
26 different subdivisions
i don't know what's going on
and our boundaries are the ohio river to
the west west broadway to the north 34th
street to the east and
on the south is miles park the
industrial park
some of the advocacy encompassment of
the chickasaw neighborhood is the vacant
and abandoned property improvements
chickasaw park improvements
and housing and quality of life
preservation
i don't know why i keep going back to
that
chickasaw is a fence line neighborhood
and that means where a neighborhood is
located near a dangerous industrial and
commercial facilities that put residents
at risk for daily toxic pollution
chemical releases and exposure
uh chickasaw neighborhood is located
near the rubbertown industrial park in
western louisville
fenceline areas are disproportionately
black latino and individuals living in
poverty
fence line areas are more heavily
impacted by pollution due to low access
to healthy food and other environmental
factors
cancer risks are higher for residents
living in fence line neighborhood which
is a major concern for us in chickasaw
the rubber rubbertown industrial park is
an industrial area with companies that
are producing a variety of toxic
chemicals and materials
for decades west louisville and nearby
residents have complained of the quality
of life and health problems attributed
to rubbertown i just remember it's
growing up in west louisville and
definitely there was
horrible foul orders that were being
admitted from rubber town that has
recently been uh
addressed however the residents are
still concerned about the pollution
issues
the environmental impacts of
neighborhoods and particularly
louisville living in nearby uh dangerous
facilities in louisville 60 of our
residents live within three miles of
dangerous facilities
when it comes to our black in
poor populations 92 percent of our
residents live near fence line areas
louisville ranks at top on schools and
medical facilities located within fence
line areas
and high risk chemical and commercial
facilities threaten resident health
quality of life and even neighborhood
culture
and those are the issues that we have
here in west louisville and in
chickasaws it relates to rubber town and
environmental pollution and the quality
of life in particular we have a park
this basically borders the rubbertown
industrial park and that impacts the
ability to actually
live work and play within the
neighborhood and based on the impacts of
the pollution and exposure to pollution
the princeline neighborhood activism and
advocacy
for decades resident organizations such
as rovertown emergency action and the
west jefferson county community task
force have advocated for more action and
controls in areas of air emissions and
pollution i definitely want to recognize
definitely ebony cochran who uh is the
lead at the rubbertown emergency action
group she has been a great uh benefit to
our louisville community on addressing
area pollution as well as arnita gatson
with the west jefferson county community
task force um
due to basically
strong community action in 2005
the city of louisville ratified this
strategic toxic air reduction program
which is known as star
as an effort to reduce toxic air
contaminants in uh in the community uh
this is kind of a very innovative and
unique program that is
relevant to louisville on addressing uh
environmental pollutions in in the
community
and has been a great benefit on
improving the
some some part of our air quality
in 2018 react collaborated with eight
other us communities to work together
through the
environmental justice health alliance
for chemical reform to research
solutions for fence line areas and you
and what do you know we've just been
very active on addressing this is in our
quality of life uh and just you know how
we live and our health impacts in in the
state of louisville and when it comes to
the western louisville we have a lower
uh
life expectancy as it relates to
individuals in other parts of the county
and so this is definitely an issue that
we
give great attention to
and one of our key
components is finding solutions and
advocating for solutions for our
environmental pollution matters
and some of the solutions that we kind
of
push forward uh for the community is
that required that these industrial
facilities share information on hazards
and emergency response plans and
solutions with workers and finish line
communities you know when we're worried
about uh and considering the how the
impact of quality life of these
industries have on residents we also
look at to you know get very concerned
about the workers who are also come back
to the community and and these solutions
may impact their families so definitely
this effort is very collaborative uh on
addressing all aspects of how these
industrial pollutions impact our
communities
strengthen and enforce health and safety
guidelines is a strong component for
that we do advocate on the community
level
prohibit new and expanded facilities
near homes and schools and as as
previously would address about reading
and understanding permits that's
something that we're working through in
our community of really getting uh
a notice of when those permits will come
out and how neighborhood groups and
individuals can respond to permits for
new facilities and expanded facilities
nearby uh
our communities and so that's something
that we definitely concerned about
require facilities to continuously
monitor report and reduce emissions
pollutions
as well as require facilities to use as
store chemical uh and materials to adopt
safety processes whenever possible
and when it comes to the chickasaw
community we are a
small but aging community and when it
comes to addressing and being so closely
uh
located near rubber town in these
industrial and chemical plants one of
the issues like you know the possible uh
explosion or disaster that may result
at these particular plants and how the
community can respond and we definitely
are pressing that the city and state put
forth a evacuation plan
uh for the neighborhood just in case of
that particular situation happens
as we
uh
was addressed earlier about shelter in
place oftentimes when dealing with
chemical exposure one of the things they
um kind of
encourage the residents to do if if
there's an issue is to shelter and place
however when you're considering west
louisville and our in the west local
homes which are mentioned in many of
these homes are aging and old homes that
are porous and
and so therefore actually a lot of the
residents are concerned that by just
staying in the home does that really
reduce my exposure to toxic contaminants
or maybe in the air uh
and so and so if there's another
solution that's possible of actually not
sheltering in place but actually
evacuating from the area and meaning
that many of our residents are elderly
many of our residents do not have
transportation there needs to be a
conservative plan
to put in place in if it's necessary to
evacuate residents from these defense
violence communities when there is a
major disaster that may occur
and because yes that was i think
if i can think back it was around in
2011
that one of the chemical plants at uh
rubber town actually had an explosion
that resulted in the death of two of his
workers and serious injury to another
two workers uh and the community was
very concerned on what was that
explosion impact on the community we
were told that it was the impact would
be minor and in the community of being
trusting of the information that's being
shared by these companies and these
public agencies and so just working
together with the community and engaging
with the community
to build for us to come up with better
solutions and to better address our
environment to pollution we're all as
excellent when it comes to that you know
when we in neighborhoods we're not
looking at quality air and our quality
of water
but also the quality of our soil as well
in many of our urban communities and
definitely our low income communities
there's a price for more
for uh better food access but an issue
with the persian gardening within these
communities is the uh
whether the soil is contaminated and
and that work for the gardening in these
three
uh with this soil is a viable option to
improve their health and overall this
chickasaw we you know our strong
community we have some great advocates
but our work is working collaborative
not only with other neighborhood groups
but community groups that are addressing
this particular issue this is
um
it's a community-wide uh issue that
requires all of us to be involved and we
definitely as a community group we
definitely look to partner with
our educational institutions that can
provide us with the resources and the
information needed for us to have a
better stance and be a to advocate for
better solutions for our community
the next slide just provides you with
some you know resources on activities of
environments in louisville and
particularly in the chickasaw
neighborhood and activities involving
react and the west jefferson county
committee task force
and with that that
basically uh our presentation are
regarding the environmental uh justice
and impacts for the chicago hood and we
definitely welcome any questions or
concerns you guys have that i can
address
thank you so much donovan for joining us
this afternoon
as our listeners have listened to our
panelists again please put your
questions in q a
your talks have all highlighted so this
is for all of our panelists all three of
our panelists this afternoon your talks
have have all highlighted the importance
of making environmental health
disparities a top priority for national
state and local agencies
i want to first thank you for the work
that each of you are doing thank you so
much
a question
i'm sure that in many
of our many of our audience would want
to join in the efforts
of addressing these disparities
what suggestions do you have for our
audience and how they can get involved
if i may jump
okay
go ahead how are you
go ahead heather
sure uh
there was a document that should be
available in the resources and that has
a lot of funding opportunities
announcements
podcasts to learn about more
research that's ongoing
and then
there's also requests for information
so these are great ways to get involved
and inform what's happening at least on
a national level and then of course
always encourage being aware of
legislation that's going through whether
it's a national
state or even in your local community
and making making it known you know how
important
these environmental health disparities
and environmental justice
issues and initiatives are to you thanks
[Music]
uh if i may add in i would just
encourage individuals definitely uh
lay individuals to just get involved in
your neighborhood or community groups
that are addressing environmental issues
uh they definitely will need your help
and that's just definitely a collective
way to addressing it uh and
definitely you know and and creating
partnerships with other agencies and as
well as you know as far as here at uk
uh is working together uh on community
action and and and more importantly
collaborating to put forth and advance
policy changes that can have a positive
and beneficial impact on our communities
and i want to uh you know echo uh that
you know we we always appreciate
public input when it comes to uh
regulation and and policies
um because you know
sometimes we don't necessarily know all
the caveats unless people make us aware
um so we appreciate public input so uh
hopefully we'll be making that easier
for folks to
you know
identify and to
to provide comments and and of course um
getting involved at the grassroots level
in your community and and really getting
to know your community needs is always
important um and often you know we can
um
you know
help people uh connect to resources
um if we can
work with them on various and sundry
things and um i will say that
yeah we have an environmental leadership
program where we have people do
voluntary projects for environmental
improvements so
uh we'd love to work with some um local
grassroots folks and maybe connect them
with uh you know
entities looking to do good in their
communities too so it's it's a a match
where you know maybe we can get uh
someone to pay for raised beds for a
community garden uh where the soil
doesn't you know where soil becomes a
non-issue um so i would love to to to
you know uh maybe try to find ways to
make that happen too so
um i i think if we can sort of
communicate and and make those
connections uh a lot of great things can
happen so
we have another question
oh
go ahead
uh so we have another no
go ahead donovan sorry
i'll just say we're welcome to partner
with you guys at uk here in west
louisville so definitely reach out
good deal
you so much and one question is specific
for heather
uh how will president biden's climate
plan impact the research priorities at
nie hs i'm not sure if you
uh well
certainly
very directly i mean when a
president has an agenda
that
you know calls for
you know for example the justice 40
calls for reinvestment in uh
in communities that are impacted by
climate change uh so that that is
that means that federal investment
um
to make sure that we're reaching that 40
percent level so that's one example
um sometimes when a legislation like
this goes through
it also it it means the creation of new
funds so it
leads to enhancement of opportunities
like the ones that i described
um previously
and so
that it's too early at this point to
know if that's going to be the case but
that's certainly another way that it
would um make those priorities more
known to niehs
and then the other the other
mission
the white house environmental justice
advisory committee when committees like
that form and look across the government
at opportunities they also identify gaps
in research and that is used by our
institute to uh you know develop
statements about the types of work that
we feel is necessary
and those don't get advertised through
notice of intent to publish
or other means
you know that are
that come before a request for
applications might go out
thanks for that question
thank you so much heather
another question was can the study of
the effects of strip mining
and mountaintop removal mining on the
health of nearby communities now be
completed it was shelved during the last
administration
well uh what i can say is that the
united states environmental protection
agency has developed a new
mountain and uh minerals division i'm
not using the right name there but i do
know that
the impacts of mining is something that
is very much front and center on this
new
office within the epa
so uh i
i don't know that there were
reasons uh you know within the national
institute of environmental health
sciences and i think it's true for
several other agencies doing funding a
lot of times the um the work is proposed
by the app
what the questioner described is
something that
does sound like it falls it does sound
like it falls within the niehs
mission and
you know
talking with a program officer might be
a way to find out how the work that they
are interested in doing could be funded
because i'm not aware of any
restrictions against that um
just that there might not have been any
specific
announcements going out about it
thanks
thank you again heather and i want to
take the last few moments to thank our
audience and again thank our panelists
health disparities and health equity
work across our neighborhoods and how
the environment impacts
us all is a extreme top priority and so
thank you so much for all of your hard
work and i hope our panelists i hope our
audience was moved to think about action
and how we can all work together to
impact change
you aaron do you have any closing
remarks
yes thank you getting my webcam back on
that was remarkable i'm i'm just amazed
great excellent work machine gun and
still the
that is still there that we still need
to take up the torch and do do work so
uh thank you everyone uh i want to
let everyone now take a break we have a
much
needed personal comfort break we will
begin again at 205
we have an incredible lineup of breakout
sessions featuring
cutting edge research environmental
action that you can get involved now
with water quality and water monitoring
enviro atlas is here with epa
and then please join us um following the
breakout session um
for a final wrap-up uh we look forward
to seeing you all back
in the breakouts thank you we'll take
five six minutes see you then